Let's do one more, critical rendering path diagram, but this
time I want you to create, the diagram for a real
website. If you have your own site, I want you to
analyze that, and, if you don't, you can analyze any site
you want. But, be careful, lots of sites, especially the
large ones, have long and complicated, critical rendering paths. I recommend
analysing a simple or a static page. I have included a
couple of links in the instructor notes for you to try.
>> Cool. And let me guess, you want us to post our diagrams on the forums?
>> Uh-huh.
>> Along with the three CRP metrics.
>> You got it. And, don't forget to
tell us what you're page you're actually analyzing.
>> That sounds like fun. I can't wait
to comparing CRP diagrams for all kinds of websites.
>> Yeah, this will be a fun exercise. Also, in addition to analysing your own
site, take a look at what other
students have found, and, provide feedback. Good luck.